foreign
[Music]
welcome to SEC 205 five and a half
things and actions you can take to
mitigate software supply chain risk and
threats I'm Andy Chang one of the
product management leads in Cloud
security focused on software supply
chain I'm joined here by Aaron hello
everyone Aaron Adelman I'm a developer
relations engineer focused on cloud
operations and security
and today we're going to walk you
through a few things split between the
two of us we'll talk a little bit about
the context of why software supply chain
is increasingly important something you
guys now to think about in an expand
upon Beyond traditional app security
the actual threat landscape which Aaron
will cover we'll cover those five and a
half things with Aaron taking the first
half and me taking the the second half
of things and we'll talk to you about
assured open source which is one of the
first initiatives Google has from a
product standpoint to help you guys your
life make your lives a little bit
simpler
so we'll start off with uh kind of an
interesting concept today whether you
know it or not you're a software company
you depend more and more on software to
deliver value to your customers as a
result of that you're subject to a lot
of the risks that exist in the whole
supply chain leading up to that software
and tell you more about the risk
landscape and turn it over to Aaron
thank you for that Andy
so it's interesting with
risks that are specific in the supply
chain a lot of these threats are going
to look familiar but the aspect is
slightly different because it's
happening at a different stage
and why does this matter to you you know
I had a chance to see some of the
different industries that are
represented today and not all of them
would say we are primarily application
developers we have everything from
manufacturing to National Security so
why does this actually matter to all of
us because today we're at the end of the
supply chain at the very least right
we're consumers and very often we're
consumers of Open Source software
now Google anticipated that there would
be an issue with this for over a decade
and we've taken a lot of steps to refine
our process our mitigations and we want
to share some of that with you too
in mandian M Trends we've seen that 17
percent of breaches start with a supply
chain attack and that it is now the
number two initial infection Factor
now analysts think that within the next
two years nearly half of companies are
going to experience a supply chain
attack
and because of that there has been a lot
of response from governments and
Regulators to improve how we have
visibility and preemptive action into
preventing these attacks
I also want you to take a look at how
these attacks are changing becoming more
sophisticated there's more of an
expression of creativity in them for
example with 3cx the threat actor was
able to chain together multiple
compromises
and then with Pi Pi they deliberately
overwhelmed maintainers with malicious
packages to the point that the
maintainers were not able to respond in
time
so because of this I want us to think of
supply chain security as much more than
just accidents being introduced the
typical dependency management with
accidental vulnerabilities either from
open source packages or from our own
developers instead we need to take a
more adversarial perspective here we
need to think there are people who are
going to deceive to take advantage of
how we operate to get things in early
because it's easier at that point
and so just to look at this landscape
and see you know a stoic exercise what's
under our control and what's outside of
our control well under our control we
have our own pipeline all the single
steps in our build process
and because of that we need to check the
Integrity of the artifact at every
single point not just from Source in
runtime we need to look in between am I
pulling the right package am I releasing
the right package right every single
step we need to scrutinize
and runtime Security will still be
relevant but it's not the only thing
so we need to think also about the
things that are less under our control
right our dependencies now
for every single dependency you bring in
you may bring in 70 to 80 transitive
dependencies so really think about that
for the one or two people talking on
stage there's a whole audience you know
70 to 100 people right same thing with
your dependencies
so think about the visibility issues
that come up here every single one of
these dependencies also has a pipeline
that's also susceptible even if Source
has the right scrutiny and even if
runtime has the right scrutiny there's
all these steps in between that we'll go
into where things can go wrong
and just to hear both what we've heard
from Mandan and also directly from our
customers about the pain points around
this we see that there is a 7x increase
in open source supply chain attacks and
likewise that 85 percent of
vulnerabilities are in these transitive
dependencies
and I mentioned earlier that by 2025
nearly half of organizations will
experience an attack so governments and
Regulators have really started
responding to this in 2021 starting with
Israel in the United States and by 2025
with regulations rolling out in Europe
and Apec and many of those regulations
in the U.S just a couple months ago
so now that we have a leveling of the
problem space let's start to think about
some of the actions that we can take
so I mentioned earlier the difference
between what's under our control and
what's outside our control
so think about those things outside our
control how can we mitigate them well we
can increase our visibility now at the
risk of being painfully obvious that you
can't secure what you can't see
there is a take-home Point here right
and it's seeing what's relevant to you
and your organization and you can think
of it in many ways the same way you
think of food right you cannot possibly
Source all of the ingredients of the
food that you eat you rely on someone
else to do that for you when you look at
your food and it has an organic label
and nutritional facts you have some
assurance that someone else has tested
this for you and similarly as Andy is
going to talk about later Google wants
to share a lot of the practices that we
have and really a list of the actual
packages with you to show you that we
vetted that entire process
but in terms of how ingredients get
tampered with right in terms of how
things can change unintentionally
looking at this list one in seven should
look pretty familiar right this is where
we already have our visibility focused
source and at runtime at source we have
developers reviewing PRS really actively
looking at the code that's being
introduced
and then at runtime we have our
operators so we have our security teams
looking at how things work in production
but we shouldn't take for granted two
through six everything that happens
between right we also should not take
that for granted in the dependencies
that we're using we can't just count on
Source control being the point where
security takes place to give a good
example of things that happen in the
Middle look at code Cove in 2021
where a malicious actor got credentials
to a GCS bucket and uploaded a malicious
package still included the working code
everything looked good in Source but the
package was in the place where
developers are pooling from
so now that we have a sense of why we
need to care about visibility
let's look at all the different ways
that we can get out Beyond just
vulnerabilities so one through three
should look awfully familiar there is
nothing new here
what is new however is the place at
which these things are being introduced
right we've dealt with malware and typo
squatting forever but think about typo
squatting for example or using a
similarly named website that turns out
to be a malicious one initially that was
intended at employees of a company or
customers of a company
to send them to a phishing site now
however we're seeing the same technique
being applied to Developers
a good example would be colorama where
color with the British spelling with an
additional U contained a malicious
package so for anyone who naturally
spells color with a u it was very
intentionally easy to bring this in and
the mitigations to this you know think
about it just looking at cves is not
going to catch something of this nature
which you need is threat intelligence
you need to have insight into how the
open source packages are being used like
how many people are consuming it there's
a lot more than just the traditional
vulnerabilities
similarly Beyond vulnerabilities there's
how things work in production in runtime
and this has been a big focus on
application security where all the noise
of cves and CVSs scores that were not
relevant to an organization you know has
come to a head and we realize it's
overwhelming it's combinatorially
explosive we care about the things that
apply to us not every single
vulnerability Under the Sun so seeing
the way that vulnerabilities can be
chained together and especially in our
dependencies which is sometimes
concealed from us is key here
so now that we have a sense of the need
to increase visibility right not just in
general but in depth to the things that
matter to us and also a sense that we're
not just managing vulnerabilities
there's active threats early in our
environment
let's start to think about
how we can form
a consistent
way of determining whether to know or
trust a supplier right this is this is
requirement
and you look at this initially and you
say well how do I know or trust anyone
but there's a consistent set of traits
that we can look for that helps to give
us assurance
and there's a lot here the through line
is that if one of these fails the others
are like a strand of rope that support
the rest of the process right and I
really want to call your attention to
two and eight provenance and attestation
and showing evidence of assurance
looking back at our ingredients this is
really our way of saying for all the
potentially millions of transitive
dependencies we're using
we have as best a sense as possible that
they have gone through the right process
to deliver this to us so with all that
said I want to introduce Andy back to
the stage to show some of the solutions
that we have thanks Aaron
so
how many of you folks have heard about
s-bombs raise your hand
how many folks think you know what
you're going to be doing with your
s-bombs
right so I think one of the key things
that says Aaron pointed out it's super
important to know your surface your tax
surface so all the pieces that compose
your software so s-bombs do a great job
there but as we'll talk a little bit
more there's nuances about both where
s-bombs are generated the type of
information you get from them today that
set a Min bar and where more you can do
with them
so minimally Cesar's requirements not
surprisingly are you obviously have to
identify your package you know where it
came from you know the vulnerabilities
you know the dependency chain
you know you know how the licensing and
when this was last checked
the challenge is there are multiple ways
for you to get us bombs so when you look
at the source code side you're getting
essentially the build information of all
the possible things that can be pulled
in as you go through the pipeline you
start mixing build dependencies with
potentially packaging and runtime
dependencies and ultimately you know
when you get into production you have
dependency injection cases you have
cases where different aspects of the
code talk replicated versions of
functions call slightly different
dependencies so it's important to know
as you go through here what information
is solid and assured at each point and
what you actually have to make up for
nice thing about runtime you'll see
especially in things like Java just the
dependencies you pull in but you won't
then see by their name what the transit
dependencies there are from there so you
have to stitch it all together
key thing then is using the version of
the s-bomb when you've gotten it for the
right purpose right so number one as we
talked about your attack surface your
dependencies are not static they're
Dynamic you know what you have in build
only a subset of those are likely to be
used by the calling function the call
graph the actual running and it can
change run to run so being under able to
understand
how those dependencies are being used if
you've pinned the dependencies so
actually you get a specific known
version or it's a you know a range or a
version above so now what you're
dependent on will change over time as
the package updates those are all things
that you have to factor in when you
start generating your s-bomb if your
goal first and foremost is to establish
you know a basic list that you can serve
to others
you're able to do that effectively but
you have to dive in more if you actually
want to use these now to effectively
impact your security
so as the surface of pencies can evolve
in change over time with the stage it's
important also to figure out and I think
most of us have seen this it's actually
pretty straightforward to find big lists
of vulnerabilities the hard part is to
figure out how to prioritize them which
ones are relevant and ultimately which
ones are exploitable because if you have
limited resources you need to focus on
the ones that have the most risk and
security impact and some of the
characteristics of what gets involved in
determining what to prioritize are
number one not surprisingly the nature
of the vulnerability itself it's
criticality but also important is what
else is in the code that you're running
and are there chainable paths between
different vulnerabilities which may not
be as critical but together allow a
customer to explore the threat actor to
exploit things and then at each stage
are things reachable right so if you're
running an innovation workload in a
totally clean room air gap area network
vulnerabilities are probably less
impactful if you're running it on the
public internet they're hugely impactful
and then the other piece that's missing
in traditional app security from purely
the workload and application side is
what's the effect and impact with
contextual security so applications
don't run in a vacuum they run in an
actual infrastructure with security
controls that are in the environment
around it so if whether you have WAFF
rules you have rasp you have other
Technologies in place that can block
particular types of
input injection those also impact
whether the particular vulnerability is
critical to you in context so net net
that effective security and risk is
really a function of the intersection of
what's reachable and callable and what
is the Environmental applied security
controls
in addition as we just talked about
through the different places you can get
at spam it's important again to know the
limitations of where you're pulling the
s-bomb from how much Insight it's giving
you either into the list of dependencies
you have and the ones that matter
and then I think there's you know an
importance to think about Assurance like
what is the guarantee that the s-bomb
you're generating reflects the true
state so again if you're scanning
binaries you're going to get the
packages that are listed in depancy but
you're not necessarily going to just get
their Transit dependencies because those
are called by that package unless you
have to then scan the binary of those
and so it's important as a provider
vesponds to understand where those
boundaries are to be clear and declare
for your customers internal external
whether security regulatory audit what
you actually control and where that
limit is for
vulnerabilities for dependencies and for
the chaining of those together
specifically if you don't get the
dependency list you've now left a huge
attack surface that's available and
exploitable by bad guys
and for us at Google as Aaron pointed
out Beyond just the minimal things you
put into s-bombs we think about the plus
plus right in addition knowing what
security tools were run against that
what versions of those security tools
understanding the community health the
package Health the contributor health
and risk right understanding whether the
most recent PRS and updates are
anomalous or in line understanding how
overall the community responds to
Patches those are additional pieces of
information understanding the posture of
that project through something like
openssf security scorecard those are
additional pieces of information that
help you assess the risk of a particular
package as you guys choose to allow it
as you guys choose to use it and
understand how quickly it updates
one of the things we do in Google cloud
is we try to make this easier for you at
that first step of managing s-bombs so
our artifact registry product allows you
first to
for any set of packages or images in AR
export and generate a spont files in
spdx format in addition for any spdx or
s-bomb files you can query those using
our container analysis apis to
understand the details of those things
third if you want to make this a central
home for us bombs you can ingest us
bombs and there will be a cataloged and
process the same way
and staying tuned we also were going to
be implementing push generation so you
can load artifacts and as soon as an
artifact is loaded into artifact
registry it will generate s-bombs in SPX
format as well
in addition a corollary to the s-bombs
is the Vex information we just talked
about
it's not sufficient just to know there
are critical vulnerabilities it's part
of the responsibility ultimately for you
to understand and manage your software
state to understand and communicate if
your software is affected by that
vulnerability
if you understand how to fix it or if
it's still under investigation so
similarly artifact registry today allows
you to manage vex
statements and Vex files within AR you
can ingest them and then you can either
query them through apis or in the Google
Cloud UI you can view them display them
and
overall understand them better
the fifth item we're going to focus on
is really the concept of provenance and
attestations this gets back to that
theme that Aaron talked about about the
risk patterns related to integrity
so Integrity matters and it's important
then as you go through the process to
understand what's happening to the
artifacts as they go forward
so when you think about Province
annastation number one you have to log
events you have to know what actually is
happening in the transformation of those
artifacts as they go through the
pipeline number two attribution who is
doing the actions whether it's a human a
machine a service
and then number three how are you
validating that that log is correct
right at a station so having separate a
testers be able to look over the logs
make sure the actions they're being
attacked are being recorded are correct
and then sign them so they're tamper
evident this gets into signatures one of
the key aspects of how we do things at
Google is at every stage we sign the
artifact on ingest on egress therefore
able to check at each stage of the
pipeline the integrity and in fact if
the policies that we inspect to have
happen have actually happened for that
something that now is pushing forward to
an underlying infrastructure is the
ability to use now public ledgers things
like Sig store as a technology so that
not only within your own view you
understand what is the Integrity what's
the evidence around a particular package
but now in a public Ledger for your
either your partners your customers the
ability to have that type of
confidence and validation be able to be
checked without your intervention
and last thing is to apply policy right
so this is great to have attestation
provenance and tracking if you're not
going to actually then use that to
control the ability for something to
progress through the pipeline then
you're not really taking full advantage
of the opportunity here
the half thing that we talked about is
you know at the end of the day there are
many good software security and software
supply chain Frameworks
a key thing that we would advise is for
you guys to pick one right because you
need to understand how you Baseline
where you are today and what are the
steps to get better
and so classically you need to take the
first step
and if you don't start measuring there's
no path then to improve so if you look
at a couple salsa which has its origins
in Google and how we do software supply
chain security its main focus is on a
few things Integrity logical control
points like a single build service
non-unilateralism and ultimately
Providence and attestation so you can
understand and prove the Integrity of
the artifacts through throughout if you
look at ssdf a lot of the work is around
how you as a developer work through
things section four in the 1.1 expands
to include the executive order pieces
around software supply chain so our
recommendation is you know there are a
lot of good Frameworks make sure the
framework that you're picking has a key
component and guidance and measurables
around software supply chain as an
additional vector and then what's
important is to get started
so first step do you know how open
source or external code gets into your
system to do you have an inventory of
all the different ways your development
teams actually can pull code into your
system and are you controlling them
right so without that you're gonna not
be able to stop the bleeding next Once
you understand how the paths are do you
have a sense of what you're actually
using right of the different packages in
production
do you know which versions how many
different versions which types of
packages
if you're using containers do you have a
huge image registry of which only one or
two are actually in production the
ability to understand and
what you're using is going to help you
in remediation response the new
significant vulnerability comes up
and then on the other side of ingest
right how many different paths are there
for development teams to get to
production
right that's another opportunity for you
to put a logical choke point so you can
have many developers if you can control
ingest if you can control egress to
production you now have a couple
different Gates then we can start
managing the problem space and the
complexity
next it's important as you start
measuring to figure out how many things
are actually going through your planned
happy path you know our Approach at
Google is it's a mix of carrot and stick
developers are creative if you don't
make sure this is actually beneficial to
them gives them a smoother path into
production you're going to get
resistance
also one of the things to understand
here is from a security team standpoint
are you a security team that's able to
break builds or are you a security team
that's ultimately only able to alert the
distinction there is who gets the last
say about something going into
production or whether production is
halted based on understanding that you
can then figure out you know if you are
a team that can break builds with great
power comes great responsibility you're
again really need to start looking at
how many things go through the happy
path because you need your developers to
be bought in especially if you're going
to be able to have the power to
ultimately break builds
similar to understanding what number of
teams are going through the happy path
understanding what are the exceptions
what you need to do to well categorize
those exceptions understand
um you know what are the next big chunk
of work to help you make your developers
overall more successful more secure as
they push things to production
and then with any framework there are
pluses and miases I understand those
gaps and then you now can pivot
resources to be more focused on the play
areas where there are gaps
so one of the ways we're looking at
making this easier for you is with our
assured open source software service
again as Aaron pointed out there are
five areas of risk the one that
everyone's most familiar with is number
three vulnerabilities and runtime but
with assured open source we try to
address all five and we'll talk a little
bit about how so assured open source is
generally available became generally
available in April it's really focused
on a few things Google
being one of the known and trusted
suppliers of Open Source software for
you number two taking what we do in
security for open source for ourselves
and making that apply to packages that
you may use from open source also
allowing you to use packages we use
within Google they've gone through
security testing
and provide enough metadata as spam
index information to help you meet your
regulatory both internal and external
security and risk requirements
so number one assured open source is
useful and available whether you're
building on gcp or not developers could
be building on a laptop could be
building on-prem could be building
another cloud
we ultimately from an interconnection
interface standpoint if you can reach
Maven you can reach Pi Pi you can reach
us
and we're able to then serve those
secured packages to your developers
number two to address the issue of
tooling repos and process it's built on
a secure infrastructure it's built fully
within Google using Google tools
controlled by Google end to end
we build these packages from Source all
the way through to binaries for the
second item we just talked a lot about
integrity and provenance so we fully
attest and sign the packages and go
through our process we provide assault
to level two or salt to level three at a
station that's signed for you to look at
from a vulnerability standpoint not only
do we manage and scan for the existing
vulnerabilities in the primary the
direct dependency and the transdivs we
also use our proprietary scanning
technology to be first defined for new
vulnerabilities so in addition to just
managing what's in the cve database
we're actually using fuzzing and other
Technologies to be first defined for a
range of the new vulnerabilities for the
initial set that we've scanned we're
about we find about 50 percent of all
the new vulnerabilities are found by
Google as the first defined for critical
vulnerabilities
in addition as we talked about it's not
just the primary it's the dependencies
and the transit dependencies so included
in our software composition analysis for
open source is dependency mapping and in
many cases transitive closure of the
build so not only are we building from
source for the primary we're building
from Source from the dependency and
we're building from source to Transit
dependencies
and as we talked about right
in addition to being able to be secure
you need to be able to demonstrate to
internal external security people risk
people Auditors the level of your
security so we provide enriched metadata
that's signed again so that's tamper
evidence that's bomb data dependency
data the vulnerability impact in vaccine
licensing
so today we have 2500 of the most
popular Java and python packages
available
we specifically in Python also focused
on some of the key machine learning and
data packages around tensorflow
scikit-learn pandas pytorch
if you look at the threat vectors if you
remember before right understanding
controlling your open source
that's done through our generation of
assured s-bombs and vex
the critical vulnerabilities where
they're existing or new we do scanning
and management for those including
shortening the ultimate fixed defined
life cycle by being first defined
from protection against the
things like typo squatting and
dependency analysis we do origin
validation so we're making sure that
rather than your development teams
pulling arbitrarily from a random
location we validated that where this is
pulled from the core canonical location
of the source code when we build it
it's in a Google secured repo so taking
advantage of the secure underlying
infrastructure of Google cloud and gcp
to secure all the artifacts the source
code that we're pulling through the
pipeline
and it's run through our process tools
and our secure repos and lastly what we
distribute to customers is sine so it's
tamper evident both in the underlying
binary as well as the metadata that we
serve
an example of some of the things that
differentiate so licensing is one of the
aspects of risk so for us if we looked
at the top 2300 2500 packages we served
30 percent of them if you look at open
source locations and of data and
information have either unclear
uh unknown or risky licenses
and so in addition to the standard
scanning for licenses we have
proprietary technology in Google that
looks at those license files and can
further categorize those and those are
then added into the metadata for the
packages we serve and curate
if we look at the way we think about
package Assurance there are four levels
of package Assurance first that we do
this we talked about before origin
validation so that all the whether it's
the images the binaries or the source
code is coming from the canonical
location number two that the primary
package is built from Source by Google
and attested the third level where we've
transably closed the package where not
only the primary the direct dependencies
and the transitives are built from
Source within Google and the last that's
differentially signed by are scanned by
our fuzzing technology and our remote
code execution technology
so bring this to a close
kind of key takeaways are number one
there are a number of new threat and
risk factors in your tax service
traditionally you've operated in three
looking at runtime vulnerabilities and
many of the scanning tools now move that
vulnerability finding earlier in the
pipeline but as Aaron pointed out as
well we're living an environment of
active intentional malicious actors who
are trying to inject malware into the
system and the other four areas are
areas where they're actively putting
malware in
taking a look at this and how we would
address this then
places to start are number one know your
ingredients know what's actually going
in the software that you're building
number two beyond the vulnerability
management vulnerability detection think
about the risk areas that are in your
supply chain that malware can be
injected by an active and creative
threat actor
use known and trusted suppliers that
helps you reduce your risk and reduce
the number of things you have to trust
require high quality s-bombs that are
assured and as we talked about s-bombs
generated for the purpose you want to
use them for at the stage that makes
sense
enforce Providence and attestation so
you now you have a record of what's
happening to the softwares or
transitions to the service and
ultimately pick a framework Baseline
measure and improve
so with that I'm going to bring Aaron
back up there's a number of other
sessions that we're doing in security if
you have a deeper interest in security
and I want to thank you guys for your
time